the bachelorette drama continues even  after Chad Johnson's dramatic exit  forever this is for America not too fast  the Chad bear is back and throwing a  whole lot of shade at Bachelorette  frontrunner Jordan Rogers the official  Twitter account for SEC football  announced earlier this week that Jordan  landed a new TV gig with the network  Chad took to social media on Saturday  after the big news broke tweeting looks  like Jordan Rogers got what he wanted  out of all of this a way to play your  role buddy you think this is a show and  you think you're safe for now  Jordan reportedly went on the ABC dating  show to advance his career after pro  football didn't work out the 28 year old  bad boy also called out the other  contestants in an interview with Andy  Cohen claiming that many of the men have  been cheating on their girlfriends to  find love with Joe Joe